hey this is joe from home studio corner
today we're going to talk about acoustic
guitar specifically mixing specifically
eq'ing recorded acoustic guitar i have a
love-hate relationship with this
instrument because i really do love it
but it can be frustrating
sorry it can be frustrating in the
studio when you go to mix because you
just can't quite get it to sound maybe
like it sounds to you or like you want
it to sound in the mix i'm gonna show
you four eq moves that i find myself
returning to over and over again here
they are three cuts and a boost
cut the rumble
cut the thump
cut the plastic
boost the air now not all tracks need
all of these but some of them will so
let me walk you through each of them
really quickly up first cut the rumble
it's a good general practice to use some
sort of a high pass filter on your
acoustic guitars there's generally
nothing
good that happens on an acoustic guitar
below
40 or 50 hertz anyway
but it could be picking up some air
conditioner rumble or there could be
some low frequencies there that maybe
you don't hear on your system but when
you play your mix on a system with a
subwoofer suddenly that those low
frequencies come out and it's not
pleasant trust me i've been there let me
show you how that works here is an
acoustic guitar here in studio one this
is the raw recording i recorded this
with two microphones in an xy pattern
kind of
at ish the sound hole i've talked about
that before
facing kind of east and west of the
sound hole if that makes sense and
here's what that sounds like raw
recording
[Music]
so if i put this pro eq on here we can
see just visually there's stuff
happening
down here
um so here's 50 hertz here there's stuff
there's even a big rumble down close to
20 hertz
it's not that i want to just remove
these by default it's just that an
acoustic guitar does not do anything
worthwhile down there if you want proof
let me roll off everything but like
those frequencies and you can hear it
it's just a very low
like really low rumble that i ain't got
time for that so i tend to use some sort
of a high pass filter at usually
40 to 50 hertz and when you turn it on
and off you probably don't even hear it
[Music]
but it's just an insurance policy
against some big low end coming out of a
big sound system with big subwoofers
later on and it also removes some of
that low energy from your mix which can
trigger the compressor even if you can't
hear it's just a generally good practice
if it's not a kick drum or a bass guitar
or something that's carrying a lot of
low end and is meant to carry the low
end i like to kind of ease up on some of
those low frequencies to make room for
that all right the second cut cut the
thump with both finger style and
strummed acoustic guitars there tends to
be this
sort of a
that happens on the down strum so as i
just hit down on the guitar
there's a thump that happens even with
the pick because i tend to use a thicker
pick
i can show you that in the recording
it's there as well we need to deal with
it as i hit play on this think of it
almost like some sort of percussion like
a jimbei or something like that
that's happening in the acoustic guitar
track that's what we're trying to take
care of
[Music]
did you hear it right there
right here where you see this spike
that's where it comes in
[Music]
so i saw it and i heard it and then i
also saw it here on the meters when it
came up
you'll see it right here
that frequency range right here that's
about around 150 jumped up past this
horizontal line way louder than
everything else so we could hear it but
also we could see it if we look at the
spectrum analyzer to know oh there's
something funky going on there so what i
tend to do here is to find that
frequency right now it's around 150
find it kind of hone in on it first with
a boost and then pull that down until
it's not so prominent anymore
[Music]
it's not that i want to get rid of those
frequencies entirely if i do it would
remove all the warmth from the guitar
right i'm not going for that i'm just
turning them down just like i would turn
down the fader of one of my vocalists
who's singing too loudly right if she's
singing too loudly compared to everyone
else i pull her fader down this is kind
of like faders but with different
frequencies hey you 155 hertz you're a
little too loud i'm going to pull you
down so that you're balanced with
everybody else i need those frequencies
i still want to hear a little bit of
that thump because it adds this
percussive nature to the guitar but i
don't need as much as we had there up
next cut the plastic no matter how nice
your acoustic guitar is sometimes in the
recording it can sound a little cheap a
little plasticky if you've ever played a
cheap guitar you know what i'm talking
about they don't have a lot of low end
they don't tend to have a lot of high
end either they're just kind of
mid-rangey and those mid-range
frequencies in like the 800 hertz range
or so can sometimes cause
there can be so much build up there
because there's so much harmonically
happening with the guitar that those
frequencies drown out a little bit of
the nice deep low end and the nice crisp
top end let me show you let's go boost
around like 800 hertz here and see what
it sounds like
[Music]
so right now i'm at closer to 500 hertz
but it kind of reminds me of the
frequencies when you try to make the
sound of a storm or like a tornado that
those frequencies are the ones that i'm
hearing and as i pull them down listen
to how much clarity we get both in the
low end and the high end in the guitar
[Music]
and i just do this a little bit and this
is the one i do the least but
occasionally on a guitar part this is
the perfect thing to clean it up a
little bit it's like a big boy grown-up
mature version of
the smiley face eq curve that we all saw
as kids where the eq on the stereo had
the lows boosted and the highest boosted
the mids all taken out i don't want that
but sometimes those mids can build up
and be a little much so a little of a
pull down there will make it probably
more balanced less smiley face and more
balanced or maybe a just a slight smirk
maybe and finally boost the air
sometimes acoustic guitar needs a little
sizzle on top that isn't captured in the
recording itself especially if it's
going to be mixed with a bunch of other
instruments and we want to hear it kind
of cut through a dense mix it doesn't
you don't need lots of fancy tricks to
do this just a little bit of a boost at
around 8k or above will pull this off
wonderfully and it doesn't really change
the tone we've already captured with the
guitar let me show you so i've got this
high boost here at just a little over 8k
listen to what it does
[Music]
even though i'm using a pretty thick
pick the sound of the pick hitting the
strings is a pretty isolated set of
frequencies so by boosting these
frequencies the rest of the guitar
pretty much sounds the same it doesn't
sound more or less muddy anything like
that we've just added in some of that
pick noise now what people tend to do is
they hear me say this and then they do
they do this number right here
and i will hear mixes where the guitars
come in like that and i literally make a
face and turn my head away that's too
much right we just want to go from this
to this with a little more clarity
and then when we get to here we'll go
back and revisit okay are there spots
that need to be now that we've done this
high boost is there still a little low
mids that need to be taken care of i
would say maybe so let's pull this thump
down a little more
[Music]
big thing i'm listening for here is i
want to be able to hear the low low low
note so that note we just heard was a
low e on the guitar i want to feel that
low end just a little bit in the mix
[Music]
that deep stuff without it being too
much and without that thump
overshadowing it and then we still have
a nice mid-range and a nice high end as
well now the obvious prequel to this
story is to get it right to source right
we want a good guitar with a good
performance recorded well but even then
we do still need to eq most of the time
here's an interesting fact once i get to
this sound with the guitar i might tweak
it a little bit more in the mix as as
needed but i almost never do compression
on acoustic guitar
i always feel like it sounds better
without the compression than with so i
tend to leave it off something to think
about next time you're mixing guitars
hope this was helpful for you if you
liked it and you want to learn more from
me check out my five step mix guide
that's at fivestepmix.com
absolutely free will help you get better
mixes thanks for watching see you in the
next one